tally up all the Grand Slam
championships won by current WTA players
and you'll notice that nearly half
belonged to just one person Serena
Williams in fact Serena is one of the
most successful tennis players of all
time and that's in large part thanks to
how iconic serve you can break Serena's
serve into four parts the acceptance
window is the area of the car where the
ball has to land in order for the serve
to count it's determined by the minimum
angle for the ball to clear the net and
the maximum angle for it to land in
bounds so you can see here that the
height at which you hit the ball makes a
big difference as polar you are you have
more acceptance window imagine Yahoo
Ming learns play tennis and if he hits
the serve he will have a huge acceptance
window Serena isn't nearly as tall as
yeah and she's not even among the
tallest female tennis players out there
but she makes up for it so Serena
Williams does exceptionally well at the
position when she hits her arm is fully
stretched and then she has a little bit
of jump the stretch and jump boost the
height at which she hits the ball
increasing her acceptance window and
ultimately improving her chances of
hitting her in bounds now Serena isn't
the only player who extends on the serve
but according to experts she is much
more consistent and it pays off over the
last 10 years she's won 82 percent of
the games that she served that's a
whopping 11 percent higher than the
average of the top 20 female players
over the same time frame but of course
serving the ball in bounds is just the
first step what gets her all those wins
is the fact that she makes her service
extremely difficult to return that's
where power and topspin coming
Serena's power serve is one of the
fastest in the game averaging 170 km/h
that's about 12 kilometers per hour
faster than the average female
professional tennis player now part of
that speed is the result of pure
strength Serena Williams you can just
see she has like incredible ly muscular
body so she can generate a huge amount
of force but what really sets arenas
power serve apart is her timing to
maximize power on the serve tennis
players will bend their knees rotate and
drop the hip lower the shoulder and most
importantly twist at the trunk in other
words they use their whole body to gain
as much velocity behind the serve as
possible but none of that matters if you
don't hit the ball at the exact moment
when your arm is at full reach and your
body's in mid-swing in tennis this is
called fluidity and Serena is often
credited with the most fluid serve in
the spa
there will be no jerking motions you
will similarly hit the ball with maximum
power but there's a catch to these power
serves yes they're fast but the velocity
narrows the acceptance window making
them less reliable
that's why Serena also uses topspin to
her advantage
usually when her first power serve goes
out of bounds
now topspin serves a slower for example
Serena's average topspin serve is about
a hundred and forty-five km/h 25 km/h
slower than her power serve but topspin
serves are more accurate and still
difficult to return that's because the
topspin on the ball forces it to drop
sharply right before it reaches the
opponent that change in movement is
thanks to a phenomenon called the Magnus
effect as the ball spins through the air
it creates a pocket of lower pressure
underneath it and it's that low pressure
that makes the ball drop abnormally fast
catching many opponents off guard but
Serena's second serve is not the fastest
in the game Maria Sharapova for example
will fire her second serve at about a
hundred and fifty kilometers per hour
but Sharapova sacrifices accuracy for
speed here for comparison
Serena is scored on average two and a
half fewer double faults per match than
Sharapova over the last ten years so she
combines the first serve of high speed
which has a little bit more risky but
the her second serve is safer however it
has a high topspin it's awkward to
return and combining these two she
becomes excellent excellent service
player meaning she scores more aces on
average an ace is a successful serve
that the opponent racquet cannot reach
and therefore doesn't return over the
last 10 years
Serena's recorded four more aces per
match and the average top 20 WTF players
last but not least is the coup de Grasse
of Serena's serve disguise another
exceptional quality is her ability to
serve the ball without telling the
opponent what kind of service you will
make check out this ball toss normally
the way a player tosses the ball will
give their opponent a clue as to what
service coming but not Serena she tosses
the ball to the same spot with the same
body position every single time
her toss is so consistent and smooth
that she manages something most others
find impossible to replicate
she can disguise the serve so Sarina
could be about to deliver a topspin
serve a power serve or even a slicer yet
the opponent has no way of knowing
what's coming these things are all
disguised until the very last moment and
that makes Serena Williams serves
exceptionally difficult to return so far
as long as Serena's competing these
three words have the power to strike
fear into many pro-players hearts
Williams to serve